for the last 20 years or more the actual
growth in technology and science linked
jobs has been about four point two
percent per year the actual availability
of us-born workers in those fields has
been has grown at about 1.5 percent per
year and then when you look at jobs in
new areas in the nanotechnology arena
for instance people say one of the
greatest challenges they have is finding
a well qualified workforce and and
that's at a baseline level that we're
not talking necessarily people with
masters and PhDs at the higher
educational levels we really are not
attracting many there were as many young
people as we should particularly to not
only get first degrees in these fields
but to move on and get graduate degrees
now fortunately for us we've been able
to attract really exquisite talent from
abroad and so that's been kind of the
secret sauce that we've always been able
to attract talent from abroad but you
know what other countries now they're
emulating our model they're creating
massive research infrastructure building
up their universities creating new
enterprises with a lot of government
support and they are beginning to
attract many of these educated people in
the sciences and engineering back home
but there's a global race for talent so
they're also being attracted to places
that may not be back home but they're
not necessarily countries that are where
we would think and so that means they
aren't necessarily staying here so yes I
think there is still a quiet crisis
because it's a subtle point it's quiet
because we sort of don't know what the
situation is until it's upon us partly
because people quietly retire there
trends that that occur but we don't see
the real underlying trend for years
but also it takes a long time to create
a high functioning a theoretical
physicist or a nuclear engineer and so
it's a time factor that that makes us
you know not see it in addition a lot of
the technologies that we take for
granted and where a lot of the cool
things come from whether we're talking I
pod x' or iPads or or Kindles or X boxes
really are built on technologies that
were developed 20 and 30 and 40 years
ago and discoveries that were made that
long ago so it's quiet becomes a it kind
of creeps in on us but it's a crisis
because it turns out that scientists and
engineers only comprise about 5% of the
workforce and so by the time we come to
grips with the situation the fact that
it takes so long to really educate a
person to really be well grounded in
these arenas it's a crisis a crisis
because if we can't fix it fast
bomb administration has a very strong
commitment to science and engineering to
supporting basic research to
appreciating the role of science and
technology in helping to solve some of
our greatest challenges whether we're
talking energy security or climate
change if you witness what the who the
Secretary of Energy is and and the kinds
of things he's been trying to propagate
if you look at who the next director the
new director of the NIH is the National
Institutes of Health and and you look at
the kinds of things that he has done in
his career and what he's trying to do at
NIH there's a recent ring on the
fundamental role of science and
engineering
but there's also a lot more support for
basic research but more importantly
there's the leadership from the top
because the President himself speaks
about the importance of this and in fact
challenges scientists and engineers as
well to take more of an active role in
reaching out and educating and exciting
the young people in helping people to
understand it and and he's doing this
against a backdrop as you know of a very
difficult economic and budgetary
situation but the scientific community
is very much more hopeful I would say
well there's a level at which one could
argue that all industries to be at the
leading edge and and for us to be
globally competitive and rebuild our
manufacturing in our export base have
and need a root in the latest
breakthroughs in science and engineering
and having said that let me go back to
you to the commentary about the the US
auto industry and whether we should
write it off you know there's there's
kind of a story that people probably
don't think about so much and that is 20
or more years ago the US was very
worried about losing its lead and edge
in advanced chip you know microprocessor
design and manufacturing at that point
to Japan and so with government support
a consortium of what a really some
fairly large companies came together to
lay out a technology roadmap as to what
the industry needed to do and and where
the government could support what the
industry needed to do to to stay ahead
of the curve a ticket to sort of catch
up as it were and then stay ahead of the
curve and that roadmap essentially has
been followed and that's why we have the
great Intel's and and and the other
major chip design and manufacturing
enterprises still in this country and
where a lot of the manufacturing not all
of it but a lot of it still goes on here
so I wouldn't quite right the the auto
industry off although there are a lot of
structural issues and changes that need
to occur but having said that if one
wants to think about the workforce of
the future and what kinds of
characteristics people need to have
people have to be a lot more
intellectually agile than they are
because things change so fast and and
markets really are global and an
innovation is everywhere and people even
if they work for one company
are going to find that they're going to
be working with counterparts around the
globe and and that they're going to need
to at least understand and appreciate
how to at least ride the wave of new and
evolving technologies to optimize what
they do in their own business processes
and their own enterprises even if those
enterprises are not high-tech so to
speak but at the same time as I always
argue we need more scientists and
engineers because the way to really be
globally preeminent is to be innovative
and stay ahead of the innovation curve
we still are the most innovative country
in the world but where we've been
lagging is continuing to invest and move
ahead on those in those areas that have
kept us ahead focus on fundamental
research having the kind of
infrastructure one needs to help new
entrepreneurial startup companies across
the various valleys of death create the
kind of workforce that is minimally
scientifically literate and out of which
we hope will come more scientists and
engineers